mais depuis churchill on sait qu'il ya
trois types de mensonges les petits les
gros les statistiques votre majorité use
et abuse des 3 malgré votre loi contre
les faits kyus iran corps vous annonciez
14 milliards de baisses d'impôts en
comptant comme baisse l'absence de la
hausse de la taxe carbone pour cette
année et puis la baisse sur la csg des
petites retraites que vous aviez
augmenté l'année d'avant c'est un peu
fort avec le programme de stabilité vos
prévisions sont honnêtes
elles sont nettement mauvaises mais
elles sont honnêtes la france a une
croissance meilleure en 2019 que ses
voisins et en même temps et en même
temps est le seul pays à augmenter son
déficit public et à dépasser les 3%
le président de la république donne des
leçons par sa lettre à l'europe entière
et en même temps ne respecte pas le
programme de stabilité envoyé à
bruxelles
en renonçant à l' équilibre en 2022
le gouvernement annonce 120 mille
suppressions de fonctionnaires dans la
mandature et en même temps au rythme
actuel il vous faudra un quinquennat de
40 ans madame la ministre
puisque c'est vous qui vous répondrai en
vérité cette fois ci quels sont les
impôts que vous allez réellement baissé
quelles sont les dépenses que vous allez
réellement baissé et quand pour vous
répondre
paroles quand la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'économie des
finances
quant à mme la ministre avait la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bauchet je vous remercie bâches
et j'écris ma je vous remercie de
m'interroger sur notre programme de
stabilité car cela me donne
l'opportunité de faire le point sur le
redressement économique que nous avons
enclenchée
car que voyons-nous que la croissance
est robuste en 2018 1,6 pour cent et à
1,4 pour cent comme vous le signalez
l'une des meilleures de l'union
européenne que les dépenses publiques
sont maîtrisés
avec un solde de comptes publics à moins
de 5% en 2018 et je crois qu'on n'avait
pas vu ça depuis 2006 qu'il est
effectivement à 3,1 pour cent car nous
avons effectivement dû absorber une
décision qui avait été pris en 2013 qui
s'appelle le cic eux et qui a un intérêt
c'est que vous prenez une décision mais
elle est payée par vos successeurs
ces performances nous les avons pas vu
depuis bien longtemps que nous baissons
les impôts et les cotisations salariales
et je ne reviendrai pas sur les
nombreuses mesures prises en la matière
et notamment la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation 10 milliards d'euros dans
les trois années
17 18 19 et 16 milliards d'euros au
total
ça ce sont des chiffres pas des
statistiques et vous les verrez très
certainement sur votre feuille d'impôts
ce programme de stabilité a été établi
avant l'annoncé des décisions de sortie
du grand débat mais comme vous le savez
dans la matière nous prendrons des
décisions qui s'inscriront dans
l'objectif de soutenabilité nos comptes
publics et je veux dire ici le lien
entre ce pacte de stabilité et le
programme national de réformes que nous
menons un programme qui vise en premier
lieu à refonder notre modèle social pour
construire une société plus juste les
mesures structurelles que nous avons
pris en matière de formation
d'apprentissage de réforme du marché du
travail et les mesures d'urgence sociale
que nous avons également pris en fin
d'année vont dans ce sens
un programme qui vise en deuxième le à
libérer le plein potentiel de l'économie
française c'est le cas de la loi par
contre est roi un programme qui vise à
accompagner la transition écologique
énergétique où nous sommes leaders
aujourd'hui au plan européen
un programme qui porte enfin la
transformation et à je vous remercie
c'est jérôme bascher oui monsieur le
président le président de la république
s'est déjà renier surtout ses objectifs
économiques et financiers la baisse du
chômage la baisse des déficits
la baisse de la dette les impôts encore
un mensonge cette fois par omission ça
lui permet d'avoir une quatrième version
des mensonges
nous regrettons que ce grand décalage
entre les shows les annonces voir les
forfanterie et la réalité du pays
vécue par les français